[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: We're going to go
through payment systems, what
is a payment system, in fact,
some trends around the payment
system, which is a little
bit of a statistical review,
and then critically think
about the pain points, a list
that I've been keeping
as I teach FinTech
and also as I think
about cryptocurrencies
and how they might insert
themselves in this space.
Some trends around
the globe with nations
trying to move forward with
real-time gross settlement,
the idea that you could
settle payment transactions
instantaneously, 24 hours
a day, 7 days a week,
which many nations don't do yet.
Some do.
We'll get into that.
And then the landscape itself.
What are the companies
doing and so forth?
Harkening back to
last discussion,
what are we seeing in the crypto
projects and tokenization?
And then close out
on Facebook Libra
and China's Digital Currency
Electronic Payment project.
So a lot to cover.
But please, as I had
said, video's on.
So we can keep this sense
of community and audio off.
But anytime you have a
question, raise the blue hand
in the participant area.
Engage in the chat room
amongst yourselves,
or Romain would be
good enough just
to interrupt me when
he sees something
interesting in the chat.
Or for that matter,
even if you're a student
and you see something
interesting in the chat
that Romain's not raising, you
can raise your hand and say,
I see three things
in the chat room,
and I want to capture that
for the class and so forth.
So the readings
today, I thought it
was interesting to take a
speech by Lael Brainard.
Lael is on the US
Federal Reserve Board.
And as they do in many
commissions and boards
of central banks
around the globe,
they allocate
different projects.
Now, Lael is part of the
Federal Open Market Committee
and helps set interest
rates, but she also
is that key player on the
Reserve Board around payments.
So she gave a speech
about the updating
and where we stand, and I
hope you found that helpful.
Along with Neha Narula, we did
a cryptocurrency online course
last summer.
And the payment system
space was something
we wrote just as a background,
as a primer in this area,
and then some payment
innovations in the FinTech
space, and a little map
about nine payment track.
So I hope that was helpful.
If you haven't dug into it, I
do think that Lael's speech is
a good update as to where we
are and particularly as the US
Federal Reserve is thinking
about things like Facebook's
Libra, thinking about going
to real-time gross settlement
in something called FedNow
that won't be rolled out now
for three or four years.
But I think Lael gives a good
sense of where things are.
So just if we can have a little
bit of conversation here,
and Romain will help facilitate.
But what are the key
challenges and opportunities
in the current system, just
from your own perspective?
In essence, what do
you think I will later
have on that list
of pain points,
if you've not yet
downloaded the slides?
But Romain.
ROMAIN: Let's see who will be
the first volunteer for today.
GARY GENSLER: Just to get
it a little bit interesting.
ROMAIN: Still waiting
for a blue hand.
Hassan.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE] page.
You might have to get one.
What did you have, Romain?
ROMAIN: Hassan,
the floor is yours.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Yeah, about the
payment system, I've
noticed that there is kind of
a monopoly, especially here
in the Middle East.
All the payments
are, or I would say
almost all payments are through
Visa, and Mastercard, and AMEX.
And if you can see
that, these companies
take a percentage
of the merchants.
And I don't if you guys
have this in the States,
but sometimes, for instance,
in my country in Bahrain,
if I would go and buy something,
if I know the owner person,
he would say, hey, listen,
if you would pay me in cash,
I could give you a discount.
So I think that there are many
opportunities for companies
that could maybe take less money
and exploit this opportunity.
GARY GENSLER: So this
captured two themes
that you picked up there,
and there were many others.
And I see Andrea's hand up.
So we'll have some
other good discussions.
Cost, you're saying that
the current payment rails--
my word-- that the
current payment rails
have a significant cost.
And you also mentioned
the concentration.
You said monopoly.
Some might say oligopolies,
but there's a concentration
usually in the payment systems.
And this comes by
and large not only
because of the
history of payments
but also the significant
network effects,
that if you have one central
payment mechanism, whether it's
a clearing house in days of
old or, in the last 40 years,
the credit card companies became
very significant in the payment
space.
They had network
effects, scale, bringing
merchants on the one side, the
store owners on the one side,
and the consumers on
the other side together.
And the platform economics
create a significant network
effect.
So there's a lot
of concentration.
But Andrea or others?
ROMAIN: Andrea?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I'm not fully sure
if this is related
or if you count it
also as payment.
But I think one of the
biggest opportunities
and also challenges
is still to resolve
the international
payments, so basically
how you send the money
across the borders.
There are many startups, like
everyone knows TransferWise
who are doing a great job.
But when you think
about it, it's still--
the way their business
model or how it works,
it's still not basically
instant sending of money,
and there are a
couple of limitations.
For example, you
also need to do it--
you also need to
or you're allowed
to send the money
internationally
if you have a bank account.
But I, for example, know I
was working in the Middle East
where, for example,
there is a lot of people,
a lot of international people
coming and working there.
And they are sending
a lot of money
back to their families home.
And, for example, a lot of them
don't have a banking account.
So they're using services
such as Western Union.
GARY GENSLER: So let's--
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: I think
Andrea was good.
She raised three
points in there.
I see Ivy's hand,
and then we'll close.
But the three points I heard,
cross-border, sending payments
from one nation to another.
Now that could be because
it's moving from one currency
to another, or even if
it's in the same currency,
if you're using US dollars
and sending it cross-border
or using Euro or yen and
sending it cross-border,
you're jumping between two
different payment systems, two
different banking systems.
And so cross-border same
currency or cross-border
cross currency, there's
a significant amount
of cost embedded in that.
There is time delays that
Andrea mentioned until you
can have settled money.
Final settled money means
that you can actually use it
in your commercial daily lives.
And then thirdly, I think
Andrea raised inclusion,
whether everybody has
access to that system.
So I thank you.
And then Ivy, and
then we'll move on.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I actually had some
earlier points.
But I think just building up
off of that, things like Plaid,
I think, are quite interesting
because you really need this--
I guess I think about it as the
plumbing of the payment system,
if you will, because
they really need
to plug into so many different
types, the payment systems, all
these different
financial institutions.
And just even thinking about
inclusion and consumer--
customer behavior and
consumer credit behavior
or cross-countries,
it's entirely different.
Like people in the UK don't,
or in Europe in general,
I don't think, use credit
cards as much as Americans do.
People in Asia are really
used to using Alipay, WeChat.
QR codes have
become a big thing.
And in Canada, people
pay down their debt
much faster than we do.
So just trying to
think about how
all these different players,
both on the consumer side
as well as on the supply
side, if you will,
will fit into the entire
system in the future.
GARY GENSLER: So Ivy's
mentioned a bunch
of cultural and
geographic differences.
Country by country,
we have differences
in our payment systems.
We have different cultural
behaviors about paying down
our debt and so forth.
And you mentioned one company,
Plaid, that helps the plumbing.
And what's interesting is
that the word "plumbing"
in banking or plumbing and
payment is an age old thought.
Actually, when
Alexander Hamilton,
our nation's first
Secretary of the Treasury,
helped found one of the
first banks in the nation,
the Bank of New York-- it still
is part of the Bank of New York
Mellon-- this was in the 1780s,
they took as their logo--
logo is a modern word.
But they took as
their symbol something
that looked like
plumbing, literally
that they thought of
banking as like waterworks
or a central utility, sending
money around rather than
sending water around.
So I thank you for that.
But yes, Plaid is
part of that plumbing.
And as Andrea said,
TransferWise is
trying to find a gap
in the cross-border.
They're not alone.
There's Remitly and WorldRemit,
and many other companies also.
And so this is a long question.
But just anybody want to
say, what lessons can you
take from Big Tech in
this space, Alipay,
WeChat Pay, M-Pesa, et
cetera, just Big Tech?
And secondly, any lessons
from all the startups.
So it's two buckets,
but it's what can you
take from the competitive
landscape, either Big
Tech or the disruptors?
ROMAIN: Anyone?
GARY GENSLER: I'm sure that
some of you use these companies,
whether you're from Asia, and
you use many of the Big Tech
ones, or even in
the US if you do,
or you're bound to use Venmo,
which is owned by PayPal,
or something.
ROMAIN: So we have
Luke and then Yi.
AUDIENCE: So one of the--
GARY GENSLER: Which side
are you [INAUDIBLE],,
Big Tech or disruptors?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Say that again.
Say that again now.
GARY GENSLER: Are you addressing
Big Tech or the disruptors?
AUDIENCE: So let's
go with Big Tech,
but I guess it's not to
easy when I talk about,
for example, KakaoPay, which
is the payment platform made
by Kakao Group, which
is the largest--
the tech company in Korea.
And basically, it's
WhatsApp of Korea.
So whether it be KakaoPay, or
WeChat Pay, Alipay, Apple Pay,
the key thing is it's very,
very easy compared to the bank.
Now, the banks are trying to
catch up with the API Open
Banking system and all that.
But basically, the
UI user interface
is pretty easy to use.
And if you have a problem, if
you contact customer service,
they'll contact you
right away, versus banks
make you wait 20 minutes,
blah, blah, blah.
Sad to say it as a banker,
but it is what it is.
GARY GENSLER: So I think that
the key lesson you're saying
is it's easier, it's
got a user interface
that's quite convenient.
And while you didn't use the
word, it's also ubiquitous.
And so KakaoPay in Korea,
LINE Pay in Japan and Taiwan,
WeChat Pay, Alipay,
M-Pesa really
leapfrog the banking system.
But there is a very established
banking system in Korea.
And yet still,
KakaoPay leaped over.
Not as much so in the US.
I mean, yes, Google
Wallet is there.
Yes, Apple Pay is there,
and they're significant.
Less so for Facebook actually.
AUDIENCE: I think
that's because of the--
GARY GENSLER:
[INAUDIBLE] we're weaker,
in a sense, adoption, Google,
Apple, Facebook in the US,
than we find in Korea or China.
AUDIENCE: But I
think that's more
because of-- not
because of overbanking
or the power of bank.
It's more because of
the telecom services,
how reachable,
approachable you are
with the LTE speed or
3G speed you have here
in big land of America.
GARY GENSLER: So
what Luke's raising
is there's also facts on the
ground about how developed
the technology is, whether
it was already at 3G or 4G
or how developed the
technology was on the ground.
So it's not just about
how developed the banking
system is but also technology.
Romain, we had
somebody else that
might take the disrupter side.
Thank you, Luke.
ROMAIN: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: Good.
ROMAIN: Yi, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just want to raise a trend,
the loss of the payments
this time.
GARY GENSLER: And then,
Yi, do we have a video?
Do we have your face?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm just very ugly
this morning, but--
GARY GENSLER: Oh, I'm
sure you look fine.
You look great.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I just feel like there's
a key trend between the--
even including the Big Tech
payment firms as well as like
the FinTech firm
is social media.
People want to pay
via the social media.
This happened between
the Alipay, WeChat Pay,
the KakaoPay, and
also the Venmo.
You can connect with friends.
You can send stickers.
You can send--
express your emotions.
You can make your
transactions available
to your social network.
And I think there's also
similar to M-Pesa in Kenya.
So I feel like this
is a huge trend
that people don't
want to only make
the transaction
with banks, which is
very separate and individual.
They want to make transactions
with their social network.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
I think that's right.
I think that's probably a
larger factor with regard
to the Big Tech companies,
but it is also true
that it's a factor
with the startups.
And then lastly, a
question is, do you
think stable value
coins, tokenized assets,
even the initiative of Libra--
what will that do on
this payment space?
In essence, are they
hype or a passing fad,
or are they going to
do something here?
Romain?
ROMAIN: Any opinions on this?
I'm still waiting.
GARY GENSLER: We're
going to help out.
We're going to help out.
We have a poll.
This is exactly when we can
ask a poll to tease this out.
You've done terrific, but no one
answer, because now, Romain's
going to pull up a poll.
And this is more broadly-- this
is about blockchain technology,
but curious what
everyone thinks here.
ROMAIN: So you
should now see a poll
with three different
questions on your screen.
GARY GENSLER: This is a
little bit more broadly as
to whether financial
firms will incorporate
blockchain technology into
their business models.
As they've already incorporated
AI and machine learning,
as they've been
incorporating open API,
will this be a fundamental
feature in the next 2,
5, or 10 years, or not at all?
ROMAIN: 20% of the
class voted so far.
Please check the
window and vote.
GARY GENSLER: Romain,
I like your ability
to pull in the votes.
You might have a job
to do come November
in our next general
election here.
ROMAIN: Are you confident
it's going to take place?
GARY GENSLER: Yes.
I am confident under our
constitutional system
that we will have an election.
ROMAIN: Excellent.
OK.
We have 70% of the
class that has voted.
I'm going to let
5 more seconds--
GARY GENSLER:
[INAUDIBLE] 10 seconds.
ROMAIN: Yeah.
And we reached 80%.
Thank you, everyone, for
sharing your thoughts.
I'm sharing the
results with you.
You should now be
able to see them.
GARY GENSLER: So let's
see, that the class tends
to be optimistic that blockchain
technology will be incorporated
in, even though it might
take 5 to 10 years.
It looks like the mode is
5 years or 5 or 10 years.
In terms of, what
will it have will be--
beyond speculative digital
store valuable Bitcoin
become the currency of choice
in some part of the economy,
that generally 60-some% say no.
And then, who is
Satoshi Nakamoto?
Well, that was just
my one little question
because, of course, we don't
know who Satoshi Nakamoto is,
this woman or man who wrote
the eight-page white paper
and put it out on the
internet 12 years ago.
But it looks like
a third of you said
maybe it was a
foreign state actor,
or 20% said US intelligence.
OK.
So let's get back to payments,
I like this thought there.
If you want to take that
window, you have to, I think,
get rid of the
poll individually,
which I'm about to do now--
ROMAIN: Yes, thank you.
GARY GENSLER: --as well.
So what is a payment system?
Let's just dive in and
talk about what it is.
And it's been around a century.
So it's not a new thing.
But in a digital world,
in a ledger-based world,
it's a method to
change a ledger.
Now, this isn't an
accounting class.
I'm not going to bore
you with accounting.
But basically, if I'm
moving money to you,
somebody has to lower my
account, credit my account.
Remember assets or debits.
So credit means it's
going down, a little bit
of accounting here.
And then somebody else's
account has to be debited.
So one debit, one credit.
One account goes down,
one account goes up.
It's also about authorizing
those movements and then
what's called clearing
and final settlement.
And earlier we discussed that--
and sometimes final
settlement doesn't
happen for a couple of days.
And a long time ago, if
you wrote a physical check,
you might not have
it settled, meaning
having money in your account
for five days or longer even.
Now it's closer to two days.
But it's basically amending
and recording those ledgers.
That's what it is in
an accounting system.
And so how did we do this?
This is just some
fun background,
but Thomas Jefferson, the
writer of the Declaration
of Independence, actually
you can find online a check
he wrote to himself.
I'm not quite sure why he did.
This would have been the
year after he was president,
but he wrote a check to himself.
So physical personal checks
have been around a long time,
but they are basically
an instruction
called negotiable
orders of withdrawal,
but an instruction to a
bank to amend the ledger.
Lower my ledger, and
give me maybe paper cash,
or lower my ledger,
raise somebody else's.
All of the sudden, the
telegraph comes along.
And a company, Western
Union, which still exists--
Western Union comes along,
and it's a telegram company.
But they figure out how to
send money by telegraph,
the FinTech of its time.
And yes, there were
machines that looked
like this, telex machines.
These were ubiquitous across
financial firms in the 1950s
to the 1970s.
I will admit I saw one or two of
these when I was on Wall Street
still in the 1980s.
But a telex machine
existed basically
to send instructions on
payments around to another bank.
But what's it look like today?
Well, first, the
important thing is
central banks sit in the
middle of payment systems.
This was not as true
in terms of the--
I'm just trying to move
a window out of the way.
This was not as true in the
physical coin and currency
world.
But here, this little chart puts
the central bank at the top.
And we have central banks around
the globe, 180 different Fiat
currencies.
The central banks are
central to commercial banks.
And what's important to
remember is our money system
has moved on from being
paper money to basically
digital money.
And so today in the
US, if you think
about the total
stock of currency,
the total stock
of paper currency
prior to this coronavirus
crisis was about $1.8 trillion.
It's actually gone
up in the last month.
It seems that there are people
that want to take cash out
of the bank, out of the
ATM as a store of value
around the globe.
We're not using it.
It's a disease vector, but
it seems that the growth--
and it might be
now $1.9 trillion.
So it's gone up $100
billion or approximately.
But the digital money, all the
people's bank accounts, bank
deposits, money market funds
is multiples of that, $15
or so trillion.
So about 90% of the
money in the US,
depending upon your definition
of money, is digital.
And most of that digital money
is commercial bank money.
You and I, when we
go into Starbucks,
we're basically spending Bank
America dollars, or Citibank
dollars, or Wells Fargo
dollars, or SunTrust dollars,
or Community Bank dollar.
That's what we're spending
when we walk into Starbucks.
It might have some implicit
or explicit guarantee
of a government here in the US,
deposit insurance and the like.
But we're in essence saying
to Bank of America, please
change my ledger
balance and move
something to somebody
else's ledger balance,
maybe a Community Bank
for that local Starbucks.
So in between has to be
some electronic means,
some payments system, a
deferred net settlement system.
And this chart lists
the number of them.
These payment systems are
the domain of central banks.
Some central banks
actually run them,
like the US Federal Reserve runs
something called the Fedwire.
But some are run by a consortium
of the commercial banks.
Some are private.
And in some countries, they
can even be for-profit.
But all of them
have some regulation
from the central bank.
So either the central bank
owns them or the central bank
oversees them.
And usually then
the commercial banks
might run these
single purpose payment
systems around the globe.
Some countries have
multiple systems.
The US, we have the
Fed system, and we also
have something called the
automated clearing house.
The clearing house was
founded in the 1850s
to give you a sense of its
history, a long history.
Questions, Romain, any?
ROMAIN: None so far, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So you'll see how
this fits together.
But let me say what the modern
payment system looks like when
I think of it in terms
of you go into Starbucks,
and you want to make a payment.
You're the consumer.
We're going to go across.
You have an issuing bank.
Let's use Bank of
America just to say.
And you're giving that
bank, Bank of America,
a payment instruction.
Now, in an earlier day, you
could write a physical check,
like Thomas Jefferson's check.
You could use a credit card, a
debit card, some prepaid card.
But you have to give
some payment instruction.
Even that QR code
that you pass--
and we'll get to Alipay and
WeChat Pay in a moment--
there is a payment
instruction somewhere,
digital payment instruction.
And then at the heart in
the middle is a network.
Now, these payment
service providers, PSPs,
in the middle or networks could
be associated with a credit
card company, the Visa
credit card network
founded in the late
1950s by Bank of America,
a California bank at the time.
And it became ubiquitous
by the late 1960s.
Visa, Mastercard,
UnionPay in China
can both be credit
cards and networks,
or there could be a network
that services the credit cards.
But you need something
in the middle
because on the other side,
there's tens of thousands
of merchants or millions of
merchants if you go to China.
And on their side,
they have another bank.
But they need some way to access
this network, a point of sale--
POS is point of sale--
or by phone or by some
modern mechanism to access
that network.
And then the merchant
on the other side.
So you have consumer
all the way to merchant.
You have banks,
the issuing bank.
The issuing bank is that
party that says, all right,
I'm going to take a
payment instruction.
And you have the merchant
bank on the other side
or acquire a bank,
sometimes it's called.
But in the middle,
there's some network.
And it leads to a
lot of concentration
because there's such
significant economic and network
effects in a modern
digital payment system.
Questions.
ROMAIN: Yes.
We have questions from
Carlos and then Jose.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I wanted to ask, I know in
a lot of developing markets
now making the-- since
you mentioned the ACH,
making it real-time
is a big focus
and using different
technologies, right?
So could you explain, I guess,
the magnitude of difference
that having a real-time ACH
system versus not makes?
GARY GENSLER: We're going to
dive into this in about a half
an hour, but let me try
it very quickly, Carlos.
And then remind me
as we get back to it.
As a merchant, there's
a value to getting
final settlement when
you sell your coffee
or sell your produce or
a big machine, whatever
you're selling.
And there's the value
because there's certainty,
and there's also timing.
So if you can get your cash on
Monday rather than Wednesday,
there's a value to it.
Payment systems around
the globe historically
could give you final settlement
if you used physical cash.
And physical cash under the
laws of the developed world
became final settlement
from the earliest days.
There's a famous lawsuit
from the Crawford case,
if you ever want to look it up,
about final settlement using
physical cash.
It's from the days of
King George II, I think.
But digitally, it was harder
to get final settlement,
and we still have delays.
So what's happened
in the last 25
years is many nations
have said, can we
get to real-time
settlement rather
than delayed settlement
of one day, two days,
or, in the old days, five days?
And trying to get to
that real-time settlement
has been a challenge.
And we'll go through different
countries in about a half
an hour.
Let me hold that.
But a lot of countries,
central banks around the globe
are trying to get to
real-time settlement.
But the value is to the merchant
that they have finality,
that they can then use
those funds in some way.
And I can tell you, even when I
was the chief financial officer
of the Hillary Clinton
campaign in 2016,
we had to deal with it.
We were the merchant
on the right-hand side.
We might get a donation.
But until that donation
actually settled,
sometimes several days later,
sometimes a day later--
it was different
settlement cycles--
but until that settled,
we couldn't actually
use it to buy advertisements
on, let's say,
Facebook or Google Ads.
So we needed-- even
in that instance,
particularly when you get down
to the last six or 10 days
before election time,
those days matter.
So I lived this as a--
other questions?
ROMAIN: Yes, Jose?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I'm not sure if this is a bit
out of the scope of the class,
but I've always been
very curious on,
why are checks so
prevalent in the US?
So, for example, in Spain, I've
never used a check in my life.
And I think it
doesn't seem to be
a very efficient
way of transferring
money versus, for
example, a wire transfer.
But in the US, it seems like
banks sometimes charge more
for wire transfers, and
they require more security,
passwords and things for a
wire transfer than for checks.
GARY GENSLER: So it's--
AUDIENCE: And I don't
really understand why.
GARY GENSLER: --very much part--
it's part of the pain points,
and each country has a little
bit different heritage.
Of course, through the
1960s, physical checks
were very a important dominant
part of many payment systems.
It was only in the 1990s
that the US government
said by an Act of Congress
that the US government should
move to electronic
payment of social security
and other important parts
that government pays money.
But even then, the
adoption was supposed
to be by the late 1990s, and
there was various exemptions
and so forth installed.
And so we even see
now, in the middle
of the corona crisis, that you
can read in today's newspapers
that the $1,200
that's moving out
of our tax authority, the IRS,
to individuals, while the bulk
of that's electronic--
80 or 90 million
of those will be
electronic-- it's estimated
that there's still
millions of people that will
get physical checks in the US.
So we still have this
legacy that's probably
a little bit more dominant.
I'm going to show
some statistics
on check uses in a moment.
Some of it's cultural.
Some of it's
actually commercial.
At the middle of
all this are banks.
And in the middle is these
networks in the middle.
So it's not only
cultural, but it's
also sometimes hard
for a merchant to say,
I want to pay--
the merchant, remember,
has to pay the 2 and 1/2%
cost if you're going
to be accepting Visa.
So the cost of interchange
fees, the cost the credit card
companies are taking here in the
US average around 2 and 3/4%,
2.75%.
So a lot of merchants
still would prefer
to take a check than that 2.75.
You go over to China,
and you say, well,
within the Alipay,
WeChat Pay systems,
the costs are
significantly lower.
In fact, if you're all within
service, within system,
it's 0%.
In India, I think it's
around 10 basis points.
So there's a lot of
reasons a merchant might
say, all right, I might
prefer if you can give me
an ACH or a check.
So gives you a
little background.
But layered on
top of this system
is all these digital
wallets, an invention really
just of the last 20 years.
And whether it's here in the
US or overseas, a lot of these
are related to Big
Tech, not only,
but a lot are
related to Big Tech.
And then the question is, will
cryptocurrency play some role?
Can crypto skip some of these
inefficiencies and play a role?
And so with that, some of the
trends, just a quick look.
And this goes to the--
this is from a report.
Worldpay, which is a
big payment company,
puts out an annual
report each year.
And this is their most
recent report that
came out in February of 2020.
But around the
globe, mobile wallets
are estimated to already be
42% of global e-commerce.
Now, this is important.
This is e-commerce.
If you go off to the
big wholesale payments
or large value payments,
different story.
But this is electronic payments
in the e-commerce space
and then point of sale payments.
Cash is still a pretty big
piece of the worldwide global
environment for point of
sale, whereas e-commerce,
basically online using your
mobile phone or your laptop--
can't really use cash much--
cash on delivery is still 4 and
1/2%, though, interestingly.
That's Worldpay's
overall view, but they
say credit card will
decline, debit cards
decline, bank
transfers about even.
And so what's increasing?
Digital mobile wallets.
And then, of course, at point
of sale, cash declining.
And there you will see
increases in their estimation.
But the US is a
little different.
The US or North America,
which is the best statistics
I can grab off the
Worldpay, we still
have a significant
amount of credit card.
Look at that.
Credit card's still a third.
Digital mobile wallet's 23%.
And from a merchant's
point of view,
they would prefer actually
to have something that
takes the less bite out of it.
Here in the US,
debit cards by an Act
of Congress after
the 2008 crisis--
Carl Levin, a Senator
from Illinois,
said, we should make sure
that debit cards do not--
and banks issuing debit cards
can't charge more than the cost
of actually issuing
that debit card.
And after a series
of rule makings
by the central bank, the Federal
Reserve, that settled out.
But debit cards are
a little less costly
than credit cards for the banks.
And in terms of trends just
in the US specifically,
this is from the Federal Reserve
in December of this past year.
But this just gives you
a sense, 20 year history.
And this is overall
payment trends.
This is not just e-commerce.
Checks were 45% 20 years ago.
And you can see that line just
decline, decline, decline.
So to Jose's point, we're
not quite there yet.
Spain might be down to 5%
on checks or something,
but you can see where we are.
And this is the number
of payment instructions.
This is dollar amounts.
So in terms of dollars,
checks only went--
lost this parade
eight years ago.
So one is volume of payments.
One is the actual
checks and so forth.
And large value payments
are included here.
The other charts did not.
And just one last thing in terms
of the e-commerce side of it
and card payments,
this just gives you
a sense of remote
and in-person, that I
like this right-hand chart.
But the trillions
of dollars we move,
we are moving on
our physical cards
more remote than
we are in person.
This gives an
opportunity to startups.
Startups can say, wait, Visa,
Mastercard in many countries
has this 2 and 3/4%.
Maybe we can get
inside that pricing.
inside especially
as we move from in-person
to remote payments
as an opportunity.
So that brings us to
a list of pain points.
What point are--
ROMAIN: Gary?
GARY GENSLER:
--these pain points?
ROMAIN: Perhaps--
GARY GENSLER: Please, Romain.
ROMAIN: Actually,
before we move there,
I think Hassan had a question.
GARY GENSLER: Please, Hassan.
Hassan, you might need
to take your mute off.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
About payments,
so, for instance,
you could see we have the
bank transfers and e-wallets.
So my question is,
for instance, I
was trying to pay my landlord
while I was in Bahrain,
because I still have my
apartment in Cambridge.
And if the amount
exceeds a certain number,
they have to send me a
message, which can be annoying
because if my mobile
isn't working,
they would not send me an email.
So is it like the
system, the whole system,
the whole payment system
supports bank transfers
when it comes to big
payments and small transfers
when it comes to e-wallets
and mobile payments?
GARY GENSLER: Well, I'm
not sure of your question.
It is true that ultimately
sitting in the midst of this,
with the risk of going
back a bunch of slides,
there has to be something--
well, I'll just stay here.
There has to be an instruction
that moves it from an issuing
bank to an acquiring bank.
So your landlord would
be the merchant here.
Your landlord's bank has to
get an instruction somehow.
So even if it's in this orange
box, the digital wallets
at the top, you have to send
an instruction somewhere
that takes funds from your
bank, which is called an issuing
bank, and somehow moves those
funds to the landlord's bank.
And what you're finding
is that your merchant
bank, the acquiring bank
on behalf of your landlord,
is saying, listen, if it's
greater than a certain dollar
amount, we need a
second security check.
And the mobile wallet companies
basically inserted that check,
I think is what
you're telling me.
You could have that
same similar thing.
Venmo has a limit.
I don't think you could move $1
million on Venmo, for instance.
Venmo is a PayPal subsidiary,
and Venmo is actually--
avoids those credit card fees.
Venmo is a form of
account to account
transfer, your
account at your bank
to somebody else's account.
And account to account transfers
are a very important feature
of the competition.
But still, Venmo is not
going to move $1 million
without having additional
security checks.
So that's probably what's
happening here, I fear to say.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I, mean my point is it's a
bit annoying because I would--
for instance, because my
mobile is a prepaid mobile.
So I could not receive
a message from my bank.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, well, I
can't solve that for you here,
but I think that's part
of what you're saying.
That's part of these pain
points is that fraud.
Basically, when you think
of all the pain points,
you and I, as users, we want
something that's easy to use,
nearly costless.
We're willing to
spend something,
but we'd prefer not to spend
2% to 3% of our purchases
on the payment system.
And we want it not
to have complexity,
the cross-border payments
that we talked about earlier.
We kind of know that
they're tracking us,
they're getting our data,
but we're a little concerned
about data privacy.
And so you're capturing one of
the pain points around fraud.
And that's from
the merchant side.
The merchant doesn't
want the fraud,
but also you don't want it.
You don't want somebody to be
able to tap into your account
and move your money out.
And the pain point sounds
like the fraud detection
system that your bank is using
is requiring your mobile phone
in a way that's friction.
It's frankly friction.
It's similar to a pain point--
it used to be until
very recently,
if you traveled overseas, you
were better to tell your bank
that you were going to be using
your credit card in Spain,
or France, or Asia, or Bahrain.
But now no longer
because now they have--
they use our mobile
phones to say--
they track us.
They know that we're in Spain,
or France, or Asia, or Bahrain.
That's part of the reason we
don't need to call any longer,
but that's part of their
fraud detection programs.
Let me keep moving on if I can.
So there's a series
of pain points.
And I don't necessarily have all
of them, but these are also--
you can think of them
as opportunities.
These are opportunities
for disruptors to say,
maybe we can provide
a better service.
Maybe we can provide
something at a lower
cost and more inclusive.
These are the possibilities
for any startup in a sense.
So I talked a little
about the cost.
This is a couple of years ago,
but this Bloomberg article
broke down the cost, and
I find it very helpful.
Often in the US and
in Europe, we think,
all right, I pay
$100 for something.
You think you paid $100 for it.
Well, actually you paid
$97 roughly for it,
and $2.75 went to
the payment system.
And that $2.75 that went to
the payment system, most of it
goes to what's called
the issuing bank.
And again, the issuing
bank is the purchaser.
The acquiring bank
is the merchant.
So that merchant bank is
only getting $0.19 on average
two years ago, the acquiring
bank, Bank of America,
or whomever issued
the credit card.
So the dominant part
of the economics
here is on the credit card side.
There's seven big companies
in America being the big four
banks of Bank of America,
and Wells Fargo, and Citi,
and Chase.
But then Cap One is a
very big credit card bank.
And then, of course,
American Express and Discover
and the like.
Those seven big banks are
the big issuing banks.
But community banks, even
smaller banks across the land,
will issue credit cards,
and they get that roughly $2
out of $100 purchase.
Now, what do they do with it?
Part of it is the
rewards program.
And wrapped up inside of all
this is an incentive system
that issuing banks are using
part of that $2.20 on average,
on average about $1--
I think the national
average recently was $1.06.
If you take all the
different rewards programs,
they come back.
So you buy something for $100.
$2.20 goes to your issuing bank.
$1 might come back
to you as a reward.
And it makes behavioral
sciences important
and makes this stuff sticky.
It makes us loyal to our cards
in a way that pure economics,
you would think, that
it would be easier
to disrupt this space.
So I wouldn't put aside some
of these reward programs
when you're thinking
about, all right, I'm
going to be a disrupter.
I'm going to break
into the payment space.
The credit card companies, they
have a point of view on this,
too.
And they're going to want to
protect their market share.
Questions, Romain?
Anything there?
ROMAIN: Let's give
it a few seconds
just in case someone
wants to raise their hand.
Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: I'm going to--
ROMAIN: We have Luno.
Luno has a question.
GARY GENSLER: Sure.
And then I'm going to do
an overview of the cost.
Luno?
AUDIENCE: It's actually
not a question.
It's just in Europe,
it's a bit different.
The interchange fee
is actually capped
to 0.3% if it's a credit card
and 0.2% if it's a debit card.
I'm not sure about the numbers.
And so I think this has
interesting spillovers in terms
of rewards programs in
Europe are definitely not
as good as in the US.
And then you can also
see that the credit card
usage is much smaller.
And that might be one
of the reasons why.
GARY GENSLER: No.
It's a very good point
because around the globe,
the official sector inserts
them self from time to time.
And because of the
natural network effects--
remember that chart--
right in the middle,
there's powerful,
powerful economics
around network effects.
Think of plumbing again.
We only have one--
we usually only have
one electric company,
one waterworks company
per city because
of that incredible network
effect of the plumbing.
Similar here.
And so what some official
sectors have said
is, so now we have to put a
limit on what can be charged.
In the US we did do that.
Senator-- did I say Levin?
It was Senator Durbin
actually of Illinois.
I'm sorry.
But Senator Durbin, the
Durbin Amendment, we
did that in debit cards.
But credit cards, not the case.
And then in other
countries, like
in Asia, which really Alipay
and WeChat Pay and others
leapfrogged.
And then the official sector
is involved in a different way.
So you're absolutely right.
So rewards programs
would be lower.
Credit card users
might be lower.
If you're going to be
starting something,
you have to think of those
separate dynamics country
by country, very much so.
The worldwide-- an
interesting report, and this
is from a McKinsey report
from September of last year.
McKinsey puts out an
annual report of payments.
If you're interested
in the area,
I didn't assign it as a reading.
It's a remarkable
report once a year.
But this is one chart that
I pulled from this McKinsey
report.
The worldwide revenues
in the payment system
add up to about $1.8
trillion, $1.9 trillion.
Now, I should caution,
McKinsey includes what they
call account-related liquidity.
And this quote,
"account-related liquidity,"
is earning interest for the
banks on your credit card
balances.
Earlier World Bank statistics
would say the payment system
around the globe takes
about a 1/2 a percent
to 1% of the economy.
The worldwide economy
before the corona crisis
was hovering just
short of $100 trillion,
the US economy
about $22 trillion,
the world economy
about $95 trillion.
But of that $95 trillion,
we've probably been spending,
McKinsey would say, nearly
2% on our payment system.
World Bank would say this--
the figure is more like a
quarter to a half of that
because McKinsey includes
all the interest that we're
paying on our balances.
So this is the opportunity.
This is the opportunity.
If you're saying, aha, what did
Stripe, what did TransferWise,
what did Plaid see?
This is anywhere from a half a
trillion dollars at the low end
to $2 trillion at the high end.
1/2% to 2% of the
world economy relates
to just moving these digital
payments back and forth
plus the
account-related activity
liquidity, the
starting, the lending
balances on top of that.
Romain, I see the
chat room seems
to be lighting up quite a bit.
Are there questions
there, or do I keep going?
ROMAIN: You can keep going.
It's mainly students sharing
additional resources.
GARY GENSLER: All right, great.
So I was asked earlier--
I'm sorry, I can't
remember now who asked it.
Was it Carlos?
But I apologize-- about
real-time gross settlements.
Real-time gross settlements
is this conceptual framework
that we are all familiar
with in one way or the other.
Can I move a digital
instruction to move money
and to have the settlement
be relatively fast,
real-time gross settlement?
What's the word "gross" mean?
It means that we're
not net settling.
If you run a settlement system
with millions of checks coming
into a warehouse-- and that's
literally how the system
of check clearing used to
work in New York and elsewhere
in this country--
you can actually net settle.
You can say, well, there's
these checks coming in
from Bank of America to
Wells Fargo and these checks
from Wells Fargo
to Bank of America.
Let's net these settlements
off against each other.
But if you do
something in real-time,
if you do it almost
instantaneous,
it has to be gross.
You can't net the
payment instructions
between the various banks.
Real-time gross settlement is
used for large value payments
and has been used
for large value
payments for quite some time.
In fact, the early large value
model is the Fedwire, 1970.
That's 50 years of
technology that we've
had the Fedwire,
meaning I can do
what's called a
wire instruction.
But in the United
Kingdom, we had CHAPS.
And in China--
I'm going to mispronounce
it, but C-N-A-P-S high-value
payment system, the
Eurozone TARGET.
2002 is actually when
the Eurozone was created.
So we've had large value models.
Coupled with that is
something called SWIFT.
SWIFT is just a
messaging company.
SWIFT, the Society for
Worldwide Interbank Financial
Telecommunications,
I think, it's
basically to send messages to
facilitate these interbank.
The question in the
last 10 to 15 years
is, can we move from
large value to just
you and me, in essence, what we
think we're doing with Venmo?
Can I move you money
rapidly instantaneously?
And some countries have
actually moved forward.
It's called real-time retail.
And the important thing is
it's retail instant payments.
Now, a lot of people don't call
it real-time retail instant.
A lot of people would just
call it 24 hours a day,
7 days a week, or some
people might call it RTGS.
But fundamentally, the
question is, can we
do what the Fed the Reserve
of the US did 50 years ago
and the United Kingdom
did nearly 40 years ago?
Can we do that for
the retail public,
and can we do it 24
hours a day, 7 days
a week, every day of the year?
And the answer is yes,
the technology exists.
I'm listing here seven
or eight countries
that either have
instantaneous payment
systems or near instantaneous.
Some of these are not
literally instantaneous.
A couple of them are
three cycles a day
where they do this
three times a day.
And I can't remember
each country,
but you can see it's
relatively recent.
And then the US.
With the US projects, we
have this split system.
The clearing house is owned
by 24 major banks in the US,
and it's been around
since the 1850s.
The clearing house
by 2017 said, we
want to provide a
real-time payment network.
But it's really buying
amongst these 24 major banks,
all the big banks in the US.
The Federal Reserve at first
seemed comfortable with that.
And then frankly, the rest
of the banking community,
the banks that weren't the
top 24 said, no, not really.
And they went to Congress.
They went to the US Congress,
and many members of Congress
got involved on behalf
of community banks.
There's 5,000 or
6,000 banks that
are not direct members
of the clearinghouse.
And so now the Federal Reserve
is standing up FedNow service.
And you can see this in
Lael Brainard's speech.
Now, FedNow service
is also meant
to be like a public
utility rather than
controlled by these 24 banks.
And so there's some interesting
dynamics back and forth
in the competition.
The clearinghouse real-time
payment network probably
will up its game, and FedNow
will come along as well.
Some said that the announcement
last year by the Federal
Reserve was in reaction
to Facebook Libra,
and maybe that spurred
this a little bit,
that the official
sector was then
competing with Facebook
because the announcement came
just weeks after.
Now, I would imagine the Federal
Reserve was working on it
a long time beforehand.
And we'll close out
this lecture today
on when China's digital currency
electronic payments program.
China and the Federal
Reserve in the US
both had major announcements
right after Facebook Libra.
This project, FedNow, and
China's, both had been--
work had been done, but it
feels like the announcements
were accelerated and
in reaction a bit.
We don't know for
sure, of course.
Questions, Romain?
ROMAIN: None so far, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So what's the payment landscape?
Who are the companies?
Well, we've talked
about Big Tech.
And I'm glad, Luke,
I think I have
KakaoPay on there thankfully.
I should have had
LINE Pay as well.
But Big Tech, OK, we've chatted
a little bit about that.
And then there's, of course,
a bunch of unicorn startups.
I could have put another
half dozen to a dozen,
unicorn being $1 billion
of value or more.
But each of these startups
have a little bit different way
that they've broken
into this space.
Plaid, which we've chatted
a little bit about,
Plaid is in this space because
they came in through open APIs
and facilitating the
software in the system.
Ripple is a cryptocurrency
type company.
One97 is in India.
It's really-- I could even
have put that in the Big Tech
because they started,
I think, Paytm.
NewBank addressed it a little
bit from being a challenger
bank, and we're going
to be talking about that
in a couple of lectures.
Toast picks a sector,
and they really
dominate the restaurant sector.
But they initially were
getting into payments
because they were into tablets.
So each has a bit of
a different story.
Brex was about startups
and facilitating
credit for startups.
TransferWise was cross-border,
as we talked about earlier.
So they each found a
strategy to build themselves
into this place.
But let's just talk about Alipay
and WeChat Pay for a moment.
This is even dated because
this is nearly a year old,
but this is their user base
in the last seven years,
this remarkable growth
of usage between Alipay
and WeChat Pay in China,
both with approximately
a billion users.
It's thought that WeChat
Pay and Alipay now
have 92% of the retail
payment space in China.
And one of their
strategic approaches
is that if you have a store
of value on an Alipay wallet
and you move it to somebody
else within the Alipay system,
as I understand it,
it's still 0 cost.
If you jump out of service,
out of system, 10 basis points.
But this conceptual framework--
and their pricing model
could change at any time,
but their pricing model
has been historically, if you
stay within the Alipay wallet
system, heck of a
benefit in cost.
So merchants then start to
want to pay their vendors.
And merchants and customers
want to stay within those wallet
systems to keep
those costs down,
significant network effects.
Romain?
ROMAIN: Sijin has her hand up.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi.
Just want to add one point.
I think the social platform
base is really important,
but another thing that
Alipay is so successful
because it's working
closely with the government.
For example, right now in China,
we can use a QR code in Alipay
when we try to get
on the shuttle bus
or we want to get a phone.
We can use the Alipay
to pay that bill.
So actually, the government is
encouraging all of the citizens
to use this Alipay
and WeChat Pay.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
So there's incredible
collaboration,
what you're talking
about, between government
and these payments systems.
And we've seen this
in India as well.
India really
encouraged the uptake.
And I could have put various
statistics in for India.
They're a couple or
few years behind.
They're not as robust
and developed in India.
But this encouragement by the
official sector or the banking
sector--
sometimes in other countries,
it can be by the banking sector.
But what's interesting in China,
and we'll close out on this,
is now the Chinese
government is offering
what one might say is a
complement or a competitor
to WeChat and Alipay through
the Chinese digital currency
electronic payment
project or DCEP.
And so they've facilitated the
ramp up of Alipay and WeChat
Pay, but now they're going to
have an alternative as well.
So it's very interesting.
And I think in part,
this is to facilitate
the commercial banks were
losing a significant market
share to Alipay and WeChat Pay,
that the Chinese government
may well have been encouraged
to build their own--
they call it the central
bank digital currency--
but their own wallet
system, digital wallet,
digital yuan that will look
a lot like Alipay and WeChat
wallets.
And in fact, this is all
being rolled out in 2020.
But in fact, the
initial pronouncements
say that it must be
accepted, so just
as we have had multiple
centuries of laws that
are called legal tender laws.
And the legal tender
laws go all the way
back to Genghis
Khan in China, where
under the coercive
power of the state,
you must accept in those
days the paper bark
currency of Genghis
Khan, or in the US,
you must accept the US
dollar for all debts
public and private.
Those are called
legal tender laws.
Something similar is
happening right now in China
that this DCEP will
have to be accepted,
at first in certain cities.
They're going to start,
I think, in two cities,
and then they're
going to roll it out
over time in other places.
So now let's look
here in the US.
And I picked
Facebook because they
haven't been as successful.
This remarkable platform,
Facebook is so ubiquitous,
over 2 billion members
around the globe.
They've tried multiple
times to get into payments
starting 11 years ago.
Virtual currency
in 15 currencies
terminated in four
years, Facebook credit.
They came about in 2015
Facebook Messenger.
They started in the
US, UK, and France.
By 2019, they rolled out
of France and the UK.
They, in India, had a pilot
that for the longest time
was in pilot
purgatory, in a sense.
Facebook could not
get the approval
of the Indian government to go
beyond one million accounts.
They only recently in the early
spring of 2020, late winter,
got approval that they
could move up to 10 million
and so forth.
But it's pending further
data standardization,
and it's conditional on
data standardization.
And then last November,
they announced Facebook Pay.
Now, that puts aside
Facebook Libra.
I'm just saying their
efforts to do Facebook Pay,
bringing together
Facebook Messenger,
Instagram, WhatsApp
is their new effort.
You can decide whether you
think they'll be successful.
But it's interesting that
in some circumstances,
Facebook has been very
successful, but not so much
in the payment space.
And even Google Wallet and
Google Pay has more adoption,
and Apple Pay has more adoption
than we've seen in Facebook,
as I understand it.
It's hard to get
all the statistics.
So it gives you a little bit
of a sense of these challenges.
What's the landscape?
Going to do it a little
quickly, but this
is to give you that landscape.
First, commercial banks and
the bank-owned networks.
I put here thousands of banks.
They've been around since 1784.
I like taking 1784
because that's
the Bank of New York here in the
US, Alexander Hamilton's bank.
But the clearinghouse
literally has been around
since the 1850s.
It was a place where people
took physical checks,
negotiable orders
of withdraw, and had
to take them into a
warehouse and clear them.
But even UnionPay
in China, which
was formed amongst
85 banks initially--
and some say maybe the
People's Bank of China
owns something of it, too--
but UnionPay, these bank
consortium.
Next in this architecture
of the payment landscape,
the card companies.
I would note that
Visa was a consortium.
Bank of America was
a California bank.
It was not a national
bank at the time.
And Bank of America wanted to
offer its California credit
card across the country
and formed a consortium.
It later became an
independent company.
It later went public.
And it's got a $373 billion
market value as of last Friday.
Now, we sometimes talk about the
Big Tech firms, the big four,
Microsoft, and Google,
and Amazon, and Apple.
They all have market
values above this.
But Visa is one of the
10 highest market cap
companies in the country,
maybe in the world.
And then, of course, Mastercard
and so forth, Discover
and the Dow.
So that's the base
layer, but then there's
something that you and I
don't think a lot about,
is payments service providers.
And these companies have gone
through a significant wave
of consolidation.
These were data
companies basically,
expounded around 20 years ago.
Fiserv is an agglomeration
of three or four
different companies
that have come together
over the last few years.
But these dominant
companies here in the US
are the backbones of
the payment network
right in the middle of
that earlier chart that we
talked about, $45 billion to
$80 billion market value each.
And now we get to the
startups starting with PayPal
at $124 billion of value, and
Square, and then some companies
you might not be
as familiar with.
But each one of these companies
founded usually in the 20-year
timeframe--
I'll put Western
Union to the side.
Western Union was that company
that started in the 1850s.
These are publicly
traded companies.
You can look at
their financials.
If you were actually going to
go and compete in this space,
I'd largely recommend you've
got to pull these financials,
read their public statements,
see how they make their money.
But then there's the
private companies.
And all I could do to
value these companies that
go to Forbes and Crunchbase
and some other sources to say,
what was their
last funding round?
Stripe has not gone public yet.
Paytm in India has
not gone public yet,
but these are their
last funding rounds.
Plaid was purchased for
$5.3 billion by Visa.
But it gives you that
sense, putting aside
whether these values
will persist or not.
And there's hundreds,
thousands of other companies
in this space competing.
As I said, there's a
lot of consolidation.
And one of the consolidations
is around payment service
providers.
Just in the last 18
months, four big mergers,
one in Europe, three
in the US, basically
consolidation in the
middle of this technology.
First Data, which was one of
the biggest companies, that
basically was on
the merchant side,
helping merchants with
their point of sale,
Worldpay that does this annual
report that I talked about,
and Total Systems Services all
bought in the last 15 months.
And then in Europe, Worldline
bought Ingenico, which
was like a cross-Europe merger.
But we're seeing
a lot of mergers
also in the data
aggregator side.
Visa bought Plaid,
as we talked about.
And SoFi recently announced for
over $1 billion buying Galileo.
Galileo is a smaller
competitor of Plaid
that is in this API
data aggregators
space, a really important
space in payments.
SoFi, which we'll talk about
in our next couple of classes,
started as a credit provider,
not in the payment side.
But here it's interesting that
SoFi is going back and saying,
we want to get to
that payment side.
We want to acquire
Galileo and the API side.
And so a little talk, and we've
only got a few minutes left.
We already talked
about crypto projects,
but the crypto land is here.
And they're saying
maybe a digital token
backed by US dollars
or backed by Euro
or yen would be the way to
address these pain points.
Some are retail projects.
Mostly tether and others
on the retail side
are about cryptocurrency
exchanges.
But the wholesale
projects are interesting.
14 large banks
have come together
and formed this
thing called Fnality
without an I. It's F-nality.
JP Morgan has said
JP Morgan Coin.
These are trying to use digital
tokens representing Fiat money
to smooth out pain points.
And then the messaging
companies, Telegram,
the world's largest secure or
encrypted messaging company
with 400 million
members or customers,
they're trying to have a token
called GRAM, even though it's
held up in the
securities law case
that they have with the
Securities and Exchange
Commission here in the US.
And that sets the stage--
I'm going to skip over--
that Bitcoin and all of these
payment tokens are out there
and talk about the goals
they're trying to do.
The goals they are trying
to do are the same things--
addressing pain points,
extending settlement
to 24 hours a day, 7 days
a week, and lowering costs.
That's why JP Morgan
has JP Morgan Coin.
It might be a
little bit of hype,
but there's some
reality, too, that they
think that between their project
and this competitive project
Fnality at the
wholesale payment space,
they can lower cost in
the cross-border space.
So Facebook comes along, and
Facebook says, well, maybe we
can do it.
Maybe we can do it with
a worldwide currency.
They announced it was--
it didn't lack ambition.
Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook
announced a new global currency
to meet the needs of
billions of people.
They talked about
financial inclusion.
cross-border pain points.
And they said, this is
the wave of the future.
It's run into a lot of central
bank concerns around the globe.
It's run into
significant public sector
concerns around the globe.
It's still uncertain
whether it will take off,
but it's a significant
feature of this payment space
that one needs to
understand, even if it's just
a catalyst for change.
Both China and the US reacted
quickly with the FedNow project
here in the US and the
central bank digital currency
project in China.
So I'm going to close on
just a little chart that
shows Libra versus central
bank digital currency
and just say something
about China's project.
China's project, not yet
lived, digital currency
electronic payment
program, the issuer
is the People's Bank of China.
And this is a really
important question that
is on a lot of people's mind.
If a central bank issues a
digital representation of money
directly, what's the role
of the commercial banks?
Commercial banks
in most countries
are the issuer of digital money.
I know we think about central
banks in the 180 countries
that have money, and
they're really important.
But it's commercial banks
that keep those ledgers.
The commercial banks with some
backing of their governments,
either implicit or explicit
with deposit insurance,
you and I have a liability to
our banks, to Bank America,
to Barclays, to
some bank in Asia.
The People's Bank
of China is saying,
no, we will issue this
directly, but we'll
have the commercial
banks involved.
And the commercial banks,
you'll get your digital wallet
from the commercial banks.
There were announcements
as of early April 2020
that update us, but we don't
yet have the full picture.
It looks like it's basically a
centralized private network run
by the PBOC.
It does look like
Alipay and WeChat Pay
will have to use this system.
So some question is, how
different will it really be?
It looks like by government Fiat
rolled out by city and region
that merchants will
have to accept DCEP.
So the QR system
on those buses will
have to have DCEP,
Alipay, and WeChat Pay.
Alipay has taken out
a bunch of patents
already on how to
interface with DCEP.
So it's a work in
progress, but it's
an important feature of this.
And if you're thinking
about payments,
this is really important.
And what's fascinating is
central banks around the globe
are then looking to
see what China's done.
Sweden was already looking at an
electronic digital central bank
currency, the E-krona.
And they were at the forefront.
But now you can go central
bank around central bank.
France has made announcements.
The United Kingdom has
made announcements in 2020,
all in this milieu of, how
do we address pain points?
Do we as a central bank have a
responsibility to our citizens
to continue to offer a digital
currency when the paper
currency is going away?
And important public
policy questions of,
what does this do?
Does it destabilize
commercial banks?
So I think that's
a bit of a wrap.